Scientists like to talk about
the algorithms they build
in terms of the problems that they
solve, so this mini course is about
machine learning and let's think about
the problem the machine learning solves.
In most cases,
machine learning algorithms
are focused on building a model.
What's a model?
A model is something that takes
in observations like this x here,
run it through some sort of process,
and provide a y.
So this y is typically a prediction, and
the x is some sort of
observation of the world.
Examples might be, for us,
x are some features of stocks and
y is a future price.
There are many other uses
of machine learning models.
That's just one of them.
X can be multidimensional.
In other words, there might be multiple
factors that we're considering,
might be Bollinger Bands,
PE ratio, and so on.
Y is typically single dimension and
just represents that single-dimension
prediction that we're trying to make.
Now, there are lots of models
that people have built
that don't use machine learning at all.
One example is the Black-Scholes
model that predicts option prices.
There are many other types of models
that predict things that people
build not using machine learning, but
they develop mathematical formulas.
But, of course, with machine learning,
we're trying to use data.
So the machine learning process
is to take historical data, run
it through a machine learning algorithm
of some sort to generate the model.
Then at runtime or
when we need to use the model,
we push x's in it and y's come out.